Guys, this is scuffed because it is.
It's scuffed because it is.
Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry.
Hold on, hold on.
I got it up.
I got the direct up.
Direct time, direct time, direct time, direct time.
Am I live?
Is this working?
Two minutes until oxygen zero.
I just played this game.
Please help me, Date!
Oh my gosh, the Somnium files.
I haven't played this yet though.
No way!
Yay!
I was like, as soon as I saw the eye, I was like, I know that eye.
What was the first thing that got announced, you guys?
We are in space!
Oh Dragon Quest!
Kaname Date.
No sleep.
That means no sleep for Minto Phantom.
That's me!
I'm the supernatural!
Astro!
I love Dante.
Kaname Dante.
A classic Atlus Action RPG returns with remastered HD graphics and enhanced gameplay.
Set in the capital city in the year Taisho 20, Raido Kuzunoha makes his living as an apprentice detective.
Taisho era outfits, my beloved.
Sorry guys, I'm still setting up a little bit.
Sorry for the skunk.
Can you guys hear it okay?
Are these like, are these games like, made?
Are you okay?
I like the art style so much.
Raido.
Would something be a rip off if it's by the same company?
Wait, this actually looks so cool.
I don't know if I'd stream it, but I would play it.
Oh yeah!
Orb.
Where is the orb?
It's not Pacman.
It's Pacman.
Pacman.
No!
It's Pacman!
Wait!
It's actual Pacman!
I heard...
What?
What is his goal?
What does he want?
Oh my god!
Guys, I don't think Pacman should be given this much power.
Maybe the ghosts were right.
Maybe Pacman is the evil guy.
What?
Oh wait.
The symbol looks familiar.
Oh yes!
Patapon!
Didn't they...
When did we...wait.
I feel like Patapon was...
I feel like this was announced recently, no?
Patapon!
It was, right?
I feel like Patapon was announced recently.
Or was it Astrobot?
I thought there was an announcement recently.
Am I crazy?
Definitely come up on the street before.
Yeah!
Because I've never heard of it before.
They're so cute!
I want to play this.
It's Red Patapon.
Call?
It was in Astrobot.
Maybe that's why we were talking about the Patapon.
This is where your new life begins.
Story of Seasons.
My man has no thoughts behind his eyes.
He's like, my name is Hans.
I love Farm Simulator.
I love Farm Simulator!
Inspiring, honestly.
My wife!
Oh my god!
Actually, my wife...oh wait.
I'm going to change my phone's mic.
I can't because I have my glasses on.
Happy International Thursday!
Grand Bazaar!
August 27th.
Marvelous.
I'm cute with glasses.
Duh, but I don't like my glasses.
They hurt my eye or my face.
What am I looking at?
What are you snapping about?
It's Metal Gear.
Oh!
Metroid time.
Monster Hunter Duh!
Samus!
As a glasses person, I feel your pain.
Orple.
Viewrose.
What?
Please take a look at this.
She's scanning?
She must scan stone figures.
She must scan.
Beetle variant nest.
I ain't reading all that.
Blast.
Yeah, because she's with me.
We're a bit of a thing.
Little guys.
Big guys.
Now that the collab is over I can't stop yawning.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Psychic abilities.
What?
I'm sorry.
Oh!
What?
Oh my God!
Aimbot!
This script is kind of killing me.
They allow her to control the things with her mind.
They allow her to open doors.
Wow!
So pretty!
Pinball.
It's the thing.
Saku!
I really wanted to do this direct watch along because I won't be able to do it next week.
In case you were wondering why I kind of scrambled together for this.
This ability allows Samus to do things she normally can't do.
Red Samus.
Red Samus!
Color palette change.
More headlines.
Oh yeah baby.
I like the mimic there.
The little mimic box is cute.
Oh this is that...
Oh this is...wait this is not at all what I...
Gaston!
It is a little hat!
Oh my God!
I'm busty.
Am I going to kill them?
Am I going to murder them?
Yes boss!
Oh my God look at Gaston man spreading in the back.
Oh my God Gaston!
This is absolutely cursed.
What the hell is this?
This is cursed.
This is so witchy.
Everything is witchy.
Wait this looks so cute.
I love Twisted Wonderland.
I thought the same thing.
What in the twist is this?
Is this a...
Chocofish!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
This looks so cute.
It will confirm to appear in Villain Cafe.
Am I a villain?
Am I the bad guy?
Oh my God!
Wow they are all flying together.
So cute!
Uh oh, graduation.
Can't say that on VTuber stream.
So cute!
Witchbro!
That's so cute!
Arcade games?
Oh man!
I just graduated.
Don't tell us!
Archipelago
Wow!
Let's celebrate Gradius!
Titles include Gradius!
That's fun.
What's the difference?
What?
You think they are going to bring up Ernest Evans?
Ernest Evans is also being re-released guys.
I like it.
Oh it's the Pizza Man!
Rift of the Necrodancer We can play it today Tamagotchi!
Tamagotchi?
Sorry, I'm not a good Japanese speaker.
I have to get my vision checked!
I never got to have a Tamagotchi because my sister had a Tamagotchi.
And she kept losing her Tamagotchi and so my mom was just like, you're not responsible enough for a Tamagotchi.
And I was like, but mom!
It's my sister that loses it!
And she's like, yeah, but if your sister loses it then so will you.
So I never got to have one.
Tamagotchi?
Tamagotchi There's Bob-G That looks horrible Don't feed that to anybody!
Time to get a Digimon.
I did have a Digimon thing.
Speaking of...not Digimon
They're just gonna...
They're just gonna throw Pokemon at us?
What the hell is ZA?
Chikorita is so cute!
ZA
Gengar Hologram person Show me Gengar, please
Ok, ZA
That's my alarm to wake up Zengar, thank you for the gift!
Yo, wait!
Why don't we have Cyndaquil?
Why do we have the pig?
Cute
It's cancelled?
What?
He got cancelled, why?
Oh he's in Arceus, is that why?
Oh, I like her
What is this?
Do you get to leave the city?
I don't understand I'd rather not.
Thank you so much for the five kisses!
Real time fight?
No way!
That's so rude!
What if they didn't want to fight?
Yeah, purge night.
Oh my God, Pokemon purge!
And with Mega Evolution, some Pokemon can power up even more I thought the Mega Evolution was supposed to be humongous
Oh my God
So you catch in the day and you fight in the night What is this?
A Poke...there's a joke to be...Poke catcher in the street...Poke trainer in the street Cyndaquil did some stuff in college that came out...no, don't say that
I can't believe Pokemon has a night fight club now I know!
I read!
Thank you.
Oh I'm looking, I'm looking.
What are you showing me?
I thought...
I wanna see!
Is there a new Rhythm Heaven?
I'm pressing?
I thought the way it talked for a second, my brain hoped for...
I thought it was Tomodachi life for a brief second
It's been so long!
I like the guy that sticks out his tongue Why
are they so upset?
Be happy!
It's so cute!
Rhythm Heaven Groove!
It's so exciting!
No,
please come now That was Rhythm Heaven Groove, a brand new entry in the Rhythm Heaven series It includes lots of music produced by renowned Japanese musician Tsunku Tsunku!
You guys, Tsunku!
I bet Kiara is probably...
Kiara is probably explaining...I can imagine her being like...
Guys, Tsunku is the guy who made Hello Project, my favorite group ever!
Please take a look!
I know she is doing a watch along too.
So she is probably like...
She did, yeah?
The future?
OK
OK OK
Wait, what?
Why would I eject it if I downloaded it?
Maybe if you don't have enough space to download it Just buy an SD card
Explain it to me like I'm hot Wait, what?
OK
Wow!
That's kinda nice Steam family sharing.
Yeah, that sounds...yeah, yeah, yeah
Interesting Oh my God I was literally about to say, what if they don't give it back?
So I become Blockbuster You have to finish the game in...
You have to finish the game in two weeks
I've become Blockbuster OK I was still so confused Is that
the Rick and Morty game?
Wish we had this on GBA
Yes Wandering Village.
I like the way this one looks Oh wow!
That's so cool Bustin' pants on the Blockbuster herself King of meat I'm vibin', I'm vibin', I'm vibin'
Loose Lagoon
Oh, frame...frame rate
I'm vibin' to the music What's that mean?
Saga!
It's always good to get these types of games on modern systems
He just faded out Sayonara
I'm hiding still guys I'm sorry I can't stop hiding
Wow.
Oh, this looks... wait.
Oh yeah, I was gonna say.
This looks familiar.
I haven't played it though.
Pretty.
Oh, my brain.
A quest for forgiveness while outsmarting the enigmatic crow people.
A different journey awaits in Monument Valley 2.
Guide Ro in her adventure through motherhood as she and her child unlock the secrets of the sacred geometry.
What happened in between?
She had a baby?
The games contain all their additional chapters, add-ons, and DLC.
The first two Monument Valley games launch on Nintendo Switch April 15th.
Pre-orders begin later today on Nintendo eShop.
And...
And?
Help Noor on her journey to restore the world's light in Monument Valley 3.
Setting sale on Nintendo Switch this summer.
Neat.
Golf.
Are we... are we hotshot?
No!
No way!
A brand new entry in the Everybody's Golf series is driving on to Nintendo Switch.
Aim.
Time your button press just right.
And take your shot.
Perform backspins.
Sidespins.
And other special shots.
In the single player challenge mode.
Compete in tournaments and face off against a range of rivals to become the ultimate golfer.
Naomi.
In Wacky Golf, your shots could get pulled into holes or obstacles might fall.
It's golf that's not quite par for the course.
Golf!
Up to four golfers can hit the fairway together locally...
I'm so excited for a hotshot!
So just relax.
And get ready to tee off.
Everybody's Golf Hotshots lands on Nintendo Switch this year.
W direct!
Unite some of Marvel's greatest superheroes in the fight against evil.
Pair up two heroes from the roster of 15 including the likes of the spectacular Spider-Man and the ferocious Wolverine to take on the challenge.
From close quarters combatants to aerial aces.
You can mix and match a variety of heroes for an amazing array of possibilities.
And swap between your team of two at any time.
Take advantage of your team's strengths to overwhelm your foes.
Plus, up to four players can assemble for local or online co-op play.
Unless...
Okay, they're still talking about Marvel.
I'll be so quick.
Marvel Cosmic Invasion launches on the Nintendo Switch system this holiday.
That was Marvel Cosmic Invasion where you'll battle as a tag team of different superheroes.
Next is our last game announcement.
What?
Already?
Wait, but it's only been 30 minutes.
What?
No.
You guys!
Oh my god, you guys!
Oh my god!
No!
No way!
Tomodachi Life, living the dream.
I told you guys!
I told you everybody!
I told you all!
I said I wasn't going to stream the direct and they would announce Tomodachi Life and they did!
That was Tomodachi Life, living the dream.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
It's happening!
I am!
I am Mr. Nintendo!
Thank you!
I tricked them into announcing Tomodachi Life 2!
You're welcome everybody!
Here's Mr. Miyamoto to introduce us.
To me?
Me?
We continue to broadcast Nintendo Direct presentations, but we're also launching a new channel based on the concept of delivering information to you directly.
This is a smart device app called Nintendo Today.
I'll never be able to miss a Direct now!
In the app you can view different Nintendo events.
We will also be delivering all sorts of content about Nintendo games and characters every day.
Thank you!
I got...I got a Japanese Direct?
Oh my god!
I must tweet!
I told you all!
I can't believe it happened!
What can I say?
You're welcome!
For those who don't have Twitter...
I made a tweet literally yesterday and I said I can't do a Nintendo Direct watch along tomorrow.
And because of that they'll announce Tomodachi Life 2.
You're welcome!
I can't believe it!
And then this morning, only this morning, I actually made the thumbnail and everything.
Because this morning, Otiki-san from the...I did a collab just like literally like an hour ago.
And Otiki-san was just like, oh I can only play until 11pm JST, which is 10am, which is the start time of the Direct.
So I was just like, oh, okay, I can make it.
I can make it really fast.
And then!
I can't believe!
Actually, when I first saw the beach and stuff, I was just like Animal Crossing.
But that was just like, no, it doesn't look like the Animal Crossing.
It looked like a little jankier than Animal Crossing.
And then I saw the little person sleeping, and then I saw the poo, and then I was like, that's Tomodachi Life humor.
I can't believe it!
Oh my gosh, am I the leaker?
Is Nintendo going to come after me?
They announced a new Super Robot Wars with Macross Delta on the JP Direct.
No!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the super!
Nintendo is going to get you double crossing them.
So,
I did want to say real quick, I'm sorry for starting the Direct late.
The first thing was Dragon Quest, so sorry that I missed out on that.
But, WDirect!
WDirect!
And sorry that it was kind of scuffed, and there was no intro, and no nothing, and everything, everything.
I'm so happy!
This has been fun, please get some sleep.
Thank you!
Thank you so much Neosurfer for Super Chat.
I can't believe it!
I'm going to cry!
Well, I'm not living at all, but...
Oh my god.
This feels like the end of a journey.
You guys, for the past couple of, I don't know, for the past however many Nintendo Directs that I've watched along, I've put Tomodachi Life 2.
I've wished it every single time.
And I know so many others have too.
So many others have too.
And so finally...
Finally!
Finally we got it!
What do I put?
Now what do I do?
As a ghost I had, you know, as a ghost I was like, I must...
I had unfinished business, Tomodachi Life 2!
What do I do now?
Manifest Bloodborne?
I don't think Bloodborne would be in a Nintendo Direct.
I don't think so.
Rhythm Heaven and Tomodachi and Hotshot Golf, everything.
You hype for Raidou?
Actually I am pretty hyped for that, that was fun.
Gosh, now we wait for Tomodachi 3!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe it.
And there were some people that were just like, oh man...
Oh man...
They are not going to announce Tomodachi Life 2 today because they are going to announce it probably next week.
But I think next week is mostly about the Switch 2, no?
I don't know, maybe they will announce some games for it.
But I guess starting titles, no?
Did they show Silksong?
Yes they did!
Remember how much you still want to annoy Matara-Kan, so true.
So true.
Evil, sorry, sorry, no, sorry.
They announced my Silksong.
Sorry, sorry, I got mistaken.
I used all my energy.
I'm so tired.
Profit Minto.
Don't even joke, I'm sorry.
Maybe Silksong next week.
But yeah, next week I 100% cannot do a direct watch-along.
So sorry about that.
I actually have an appointment in the morning.
That's why I was just like, I really want to at least get one of them in.
So I was able to do this one.
And...
It was so worth it.
Tomodachi Life 2!
Yeah,
I think it's just Switch 2 news though, I think.
Maybe I won't watch and they'll announce Silksong, you're welcome.
Tomodachi Life 3 announced next direct.
Yeah, they're already...
They're like working on Tomodachi Life 50 probably.
Oh my gosh, I'm...
This raises so many questions, like...
The Mii creation, are they gonna follow from that...
Whatever that Mii RPG...
Whatever the hell that was, are they gonna follow that?
So we get crazy looking Miis.
Oh gosh, and then there was like...
You get to go around the island.
Yeah, Miitopia, Miitopia.
Yeah, like...
I need to know more!
I need to know!
They said... Wait, when did they say?
When did they say?
And the voices sound just as stupid, I can't wait.
2026...
No, make it 2026 right now.
Make it 2026 right now!
Okay, my voice... My throat hurts, so I'm gonna go rest.
Thank you everybody.
We did it fam!
We did it reddit!
We did it!
It's over.
Tomodachi Life.
No, hold on, I need to scan everything right now.
We have clothes, we have...
Quick build.
Do we get to customize our island?
I wonder, like...
Animal Crossing.
Look, they're even fighting!
Just like old times!
They kept all the stupid voices!
This is the best day of my afterlife ever!
Tomodachi Life.
Wait a second.
This, do you see this?
This logo looks like Caesarea.
I believe that is a restaurant.
Tomoriya!
Wait, that is just Caesarea!
That's just, that's just Caesarea!
But it's Tomozarea!
Oh my god!
We have Caesarea in the game!
Why did lying work for you?
What do you mean lying?
I hope they still have the PNG.
I saw it.
I saw it while they were fighting.
Hold on.
Look, look, look, look!
They have like little PNG, little PNG everythings.
Oh my god.
Cheap pasta and drink bar.
I'm so excited!
Caesarea Mansion.
Gosh, I'm so excited.
Look at that old man!
Break it down!
How refreshing.
It's too good!
That's mean.
That's literally...
This is literally mean right now.
Jumping for joy.
Because you lied about not streaming.
Well, I didn't lie.
I truly didn't think I would be able to.
Heard the news and came running in like a family member was in the hospital.
So happy.
Anyway, now I go for real.
I go for real.
I have another stream tonight.
So three Minto streams in one day.
I hope you guys have a good day.
And if I see you tonight, I'll see you.
And if I don't, I'll see you whenever I see you next.
Thank you guys.
Otsu Minto, Otsu Minto.
And have a good day, have a good night.
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye, bye bye.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye.
Tomodachi Life 2!
Gift
of Prophecy is just... I can't believe that I tricked them into actually announcing it.
They were like, oh Mint Phantom is not streaming so we definitely have to... I just can't believe it.
I can't believe that because I was just like, I really can't do this direct today, that they actually announced it.
I can't believe it.
So if I hadn't been able to actually stream it, then I wouldn't have been able to react to it.
And that would have been so sad for me.
I'm just... Wow.
Wow.
Okay, anyway, bye bye.